hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 7 video Carl
Grimes verse negan just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet but
I definitely feel like this made up for
the slow episode 6 last week just a
heads up - there is a new round of the
walking dead giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video make sure you
click that Bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss out on anything but they
should have called this episode Walking
Dead number 105 Carl Stow's away on his
mission to kill negan it took a little
bit longer on the TV show but it's
almost the exact same plot so let's do
top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs a
lot of these were copied page to screen
from the comic book like literally
lifting dialogue right off the page so
number 10 Michonne makes herself a
roadblock so that she can get to negan
it's slightly different in the comics
Michonne goes to a different place but
we can address that when we start
talking about the mid-season finale so
they're following the comics pretty
closely but a couple of characters are a
little bit different from the comics but
they're all heading in the comic book
direction like those mattresses that the
Savior's burn that she's staring at at
the beginning of the episode Carl hid
under those in the comics that's how he
stowed away into the Savior's compound
in the comics so I love the way they cut
between Michonne and Rick like she put
her walkie down Rick wakes up in the
back of the pickup truck with Erin and
almost goes to call her but thinks twice
of it like they're all kind of it ODS
here they need to come together so that
was kind of the theme of the episode
that we're slowly getting to that point
where things are so bad that they can't
take it anymore
it's just that all of the characters
haven't gotten to that place yet the
place that Rosita Carl and Michonne are
in like a couple of the few people that
are actively starting to fight back but
number 9 back to Carl and Jesus who is
super pissed when Carl does not jump off
the back of the truck with him now his
whole mission was to make it into the
Savior's compound to find where if Daryl
was to see if he could break him out and
do some recon so he's still doing that
but Carl isn't having any of that so
number 8 you know right out of the
comics jumps out of the back of the
truck guns blazing kills a couple of the
Savior's negan is flat-out impressed
but still afraid so
Nikken is a psychopath but he's not dumb
so that's why he's standing behind this
Savior here before they disarmed Carl
like he's still hedging his bet so when
he tells Carl that he is afraid he's
actually being honest that's the thing
about negan is that he bullshit's a lot
so it's hard to tell when he's telling
the truth
and when he's busting your balls like I
like the way negan talked about busting
balls like it's no big deal in the most
psychotic way possible so number seven
we pick up with Daryl who is now on
guard duty like you see him chained up
with the other walkers that the people
who they punished by making them stand
out there with the other walkers and
then it pans out on their base right off
the page so you like you see all the
roadblocks it's heavily fortified so
they're just trying to make it seem like
this insurmountable impregnable fortress
but the funny thing here is that while
negan's going on and on this was kind of
a runner through the episode to is that
they'd have like some big exchange that
seemed really serious but he would just
casually slip in insults like hey how's
the job going Daryl make fun of Carl's I
make fun of Olivia for being fat like he
just has an autoresponder in his brain
that just throws out an insult for every
regular comment that he speaks but
number six he finally gives the big
speech and refers to them as the
Savior's now the other people that we've
met have called him the Savior's but we
never heard negan refer to them as the
Savior's so he has that big epic speech
which was a nice mirror for Rosina's
speech at the end only negan's is kind
of like the psychotic cult version like
he's this cult leader keeps bragging to
carl about how he has him all on their
knees look how cool I am like he even
has them on their knees after he
finishes speaking but you do get this
sense like as he's like performing for
all these people he did this several
times in the episode where he's kind of
like Ezekiel Ezekiel did a little bit of
community theater so he has this flair
for performance that negan also has ages
the negan is kind of delighting in
tormenting people in Ezekiel doesn't
really get off on it that way he's more
of a Wizard of Oz type character where
he just keeps it up to make everybody
feel safe not to keep people under his
thumb but number five that car ride with
Gabriel and Spencer two of the most
hated members of the SafeZone talking
about
people the thing is is that Gabriel is
kind of like the more hopeful spin on
this like he used to be hated and he's
come around and calls Spencer out for
being a dick like look dude it doesn't
have to be terminal band gets out and
walks back just because he can't stand
Spencer anymore but he's father Gabriel
so he's really sweet about it so I
really love Gabriel in this moment but
Spencer is on this really weird trip
where he's almost turning into the new
Dwight where like he wants to keep the
peace he wants to fleck find all these
supplies and they have that funny twist
with the note read in Latin so he finds
weapons find some food and it's kind of
like the diametric opposite of Rosita
who you know number 4 talks Eugene into
Manning up and making her some bullets
so Rosita speech was like my other
favorite big speech in the episode
besides negan's savior speech he was
this huge rally moment it's just like
the tipping point and they also kind of
teased the Rick Aaron's storyline which
I'll talk about in a second like Rosita
being is a really badass female
character making a plan to take on negan
you have Michonne who's doing the same
thing and then you have the Rick and
Aaron's storyline number 3 which I think
you know they find this community I
think it's gonna turn out to be magna
who's this female leader of another
small community near the safe zone it's
just the way they use those male
pronouns when they were seeing all the
signs all the defense's they're like oh
this guy is heavily armed he has this
floater traps he's really smart about
his defenses I just feel like it's a big
misdirect and it's gonna be a woman like
a really badass female character in
Magne is like the next likely candidate
because I don't think they're doing the
whisperers this soon because the leader
of the whisperers alpha is a female too
but it's way too soon for that so number
2 Carl gets a grand tour of negan's
compound he meets all the wives this is
all right out of the comics in most WTF
scene ever
negan totally gets off on seeing Carl's
eye without the bandage on like even
start sketching it a little makes Carl
sing a song that his mother sang to him
which is super creepy and then as he
starts weeping you know Carl confesses I
shot my mother so negan when he was
saying that he was impressed with Carl
he was being jet
you win but the big twist is that negan
as much as he was enjoying getting to
know Carl more was also stalling for
time till number one the iron was ready
so he gives mark the iron just like he
does in the comics there's another big
speech this one's a little bit creepier
about the rules about how he's trying to
keep order in his society so that kind
of ties up in with the idea that Carl
knows that negan can't kill him because
that would drive Rick over the edge it
would destroy the system that negan is
trying to keep in place he does have a
plan like he's not completely insane he
really enjoys the way things are and he
knows there's a certain trick to keeping
the balance between all the different
communities that he has under his thumb
or seemingly has under his thumb so Carl
realizing that says you can't kill me so
you might as well just jump out the
window to save me the trouble of killing
you but the face irons scene I love the
way they kept flashing back to Dwight to
their reactions they didn't linger on it
quite as much as I expected they cut
away but maybe that's just because the
first episode with Glenn and the Abraham
kill was so graphic that they wanted to
dial it back just a little bit but this
was like an hour and a half episode so I
should add like five more WTF moments on
this so really like tied for first was
that final moment with negan cradling
Judith in this Norman Rockwell's
nightmare saying that he should just
kill Carl and Rick and move into the
suburbs so they're really just trying to
beat you in the face with the idea that
negan has to go so that's going to
require everyone coming together like
all the communities the kingdom
Oceanside this new group of people that
Rick and Aaron are running into and help
from the inside of the Savior's to so
people like Dwight and Cherie like
Sherri seems like she's really pissed
that Dwight hasn't come around because
he's still playing by negan's rules so
if you look at Daryl's note here I
actually think it was Sherri that let
him out just because the handwriting
looks kind of effeminate like unless
Dwight has really effeminate handwriting
but you see in the next episode he's
escaping there's so much story to get
through that I think the mid-season
finale is another 90 minute episode so
it's gonna be crazy
let me know in the comments what was
your guy's favorite moment do you think
they will actually decide like Rick will
meet with the other heads of the
communities including Dwight to move
against negan in Episode eight do you
think that's gonna be the cliffhanger
for the back half of the season and
they'll do march to war like this
episode was issued 105 that's in the
middle of march to war volume 18 it
feels like volume 19 will be the back
half of the season leading into all-out
war which is volume 20 so if you are
reading along I would recommend that you
read through volume 18 again then get
ready for volume 19 before we come back
for the back half of the season but here
let's do it this way leave a like if you
think that Spencer is gonna be one of
the next big characters to get killed
off of the show just because he's headed
in such a white direction and it seems
like they're setting Dwight's character
up to crawl out of that hole like crawl
out from under negan's thumb but what's
gonna happen is is there's like a couple
really big videos that are dropping
tomorrow I got my West world finale
video that'll post tomorrow morning
there's gonna be a Transformers trailer
dropping and The Walking Dead finale
trailer still try and get those videos
out as fast as possible but if you have
any bonus videos for The Walking Dead
that you want me to do during the
mid-season break just let me know in the
comments what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to re-watch that
guardians of the galaxy trailer and you
can click here for all my Westworld
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight